here's a question right now they say if
I define why is this right what happens
as X approaches infinity so let's
rewrite that improper limit notation I
would just have to say take away the
swiping
there's the function I'm interested in
and I want to see what happens I want to
see what it approaches as X approaches
infinity okay oh sure there's the
function I'm evaluating now you can't
put infinity you to that facade as
infinity is not a number but even if it
were you'd have infinity over to
infinity and infinity is so large that
if you divide it you're still gonna get
Definity okay so I kind of to evaluate
this so I'm trying to work out how it
behaves now in the text base
specifically refer to this method and
some of you asked me about this which is
to take the top of the bottom and divide
by the highest power okay now in this
case and only these cases this idea
works I'll show you why okay because we
had the same power on the top and the
bottom okay both degree two here's what
happens the limit and by the way yes you
still have to keep writing limit as X
approach infinity limit as X if you have
to write it every single time because
this is completely different yes right
like this thing is a number that thing
I'm going towards a number this thing is
a function that does whatever it likes
okay so yeah it gets a bit tiresome but
you have to keep writing okay if I
divide through all of the terms there's
six of them by x squared here's what
happens I get that that that that's my
numerator okay
and all my denominator I've got this
okay there you can go ahead and you can
simplify this a little bit cut you okay
that x squared over x squared it's just
going to become one right this guy is
going to become four on x this guy is
already as simple as you can get so
that's done over here this is going to
become two this is going to become seven
on X and this is already the super fine
as it gets
okay now because what you're trying to
work out is has the whole thing behave
the easiest place to think about well
how do the individual pieces babe okay
as X approaches infinity for instance
what happens to 4 over X and the answer
is exactly the same thing that happens
to whatever X it approaches zero okay
what happens to 3 over x squared the
same thing the same thing the same thing
these all approach zero right so since
this big group of guys here they all
approach zero or you get left with it is
these parts at the front through as X
approaches zero infinity rather they
don't care 1 stays 1 & 2 stays 2 so it's
equal to 1/2 so this is a method for
finding horizontal asymptotes just
before you finish let me remind you why
like this method works here but I don't
recommend it for those other questions
we were looking at before I look at this
guy we did this okay we did this guy and
to remind you it looks like this right
yeah okay so this is an oblique
asymptote situation okay
and if you take this approach it's
approximately zero amount of usefulness
watch what happens you're like okay I
want to think about the limit as X
approaches infinity okay so you do
you're dividing through and you're like
oh it's cool it's cool I've got this
right I'll divide this by x squared
gives me 1 I'll divide this by x squared
gives me one on X I'll divide this by X
crank use me you know that and then on
the bottom I've got
on X and I want the limit and you're
like oh it's cool I know what to do with
this that goes to zero and that goes to
zero and that goes to zero so I get one
so you see this method completely fails
to find an oblique asymptote which of
course if you remember is X minus 1
works for these though it's a different
kind of question so feel free to use
them though I would just prefer to say I
look there's a one and there's two
it's a